[Music]
previously when I was in IT I was in a
environment where we have computers and
air conditioned and you know I have to
dress up very well but now look I'm in
the seat where you know you really feel
one with nature
[Music]
my name is Malcolm oh and I'm a fish
farmer I started my career 21 years ago
in IT but actually my love is in the sea
I got to know many farmers and the
farmers share their life with me their
passion and they influence me and I
decided that I wanted to be a farmer
when I entered into this industry I
thought to myself that hey this is an
opportunity to apply my engineering
principles to farming
for instance when we bring in fish frys
from the hatchery we have to count the
fish and also check the fish now
previously all this was done by
estimation and by hand but now we use a
camera system to count the fish as they
go past we can then also slow down the
image and then we can check the fish as
well I sell my fish to supermarkets
wholesalers and restaurants in Singapore
one of them is candlenut which is a
Michelin star restaurant in Singapore
our reputation is that we grow fish in
as natural way as possible and that's
why people like to buy from us when I
first got into this industry nobody
believed that we would make him but yet
we are able to come in and we made an
impact and I hope that I set an example
for others so that they will be
encouraged to pursue their passion
[Music]
you
[Music]